that seeks consciousness Asha Canopus
trying out Germany's best-selling Mazda
the cx-5 it's been given a facelift with
almost 19,000 units sold in 2015 it's a
cash cow for the maker among all Mazdas
cars he says and has the highest
starting price the facelift promises to
make the cx-5 even more lucrative says
Sascha it has a new stronger gasoline
powered engine a new extras that can
easily push the price up to around
40,000 euros about half the buyers opt
for all-wheel drive and some 40% choose
the cx-5 s top-line package
like bundles the moment Sasha starts off
he notices how much quieter the new
mazda cx5 is the engineers did their bit
with sound insulation and the engine
compartment he says and the doors and
windows of better soundproofing
partially did a thicker glass
we tested the smallest gasoline engine
with all-wheel drive
it's 118 kilowatts of power can push the
car from 0 to 100 km/h in 9.2 seconds
Mazda rates consumption at 6.6 liters
per hundred kilometers
Mazda has given the cx-5 a new look as
well with LED head and tail lights
starting with its exclusive line series
adaptive headlights that automatically
reduce glare for oncoming traffic are
also available there's also a whole
range of improved or completely new
driver assist systems among them an
adaptive cruise control and proximity
warning from rear parking sensors the
interior leaves an understated and sober
impression Japanese cars have long been
known for being gray and dreary bland
design has often been the norm but in
the cx-5
it now feels more intentionally laid
back the interior is dominated by
straightforward lines clear forms and
top-notch materials
and the fauna sasha is pleased to find
plenty of room in front and back
even though getting in and out through
these small doors can be a bit awkward
the back seat has a bit more room than
it would seem at first glance he says
thanks to indentations for passengers
knees in the backs of the front seats
even so he would want to sit back there
too long the body design makes for a
relatively high loading sill in the
trunk above Sasha's knees a potential
difficulty for people who don't like to
lift but on the inside the trunk isn't
very deep so taking things like drinks
out shouldn't be much of a problem and
there's a lip so if you're hauling
apples or something that can roll around
they won't fall out on the ground as
soon as the hatch is open even being
known Lalique hunter the cargo space
holds 503 leaders in all Sasha stresses
that the cx-5 was Mazdas best seller
because it has the potential for it it
has plenty of cargo space and seating
for four people
Mazda's next big hit may well be the
cx-3 it's a little smaller but also a
bit more affordable the cx-3 has been in
showroom since last June as a smaller
SUV alternative to its big brother the
cx-5
you